i see you got the sniper gang on your
jacket
um i i was i was living in florida when
kodak was
performing at club sky in tampa like 200
people before like i was like there when
i saw his whole entire [ __ ]
glow up and like i i always should try
to explain to people like
who aren't from florida like how big he
was at that time
just there yeah like it was like
something special it was like
i never really have seen anything like
it to be honest like i never have seen
anything like
kodak's come up before everyone else
before drake started like you know what
i'm saying but like
it was like crazy how influential
uh was kodak to what you're doing and
like do you remember like
when he was like bubbling because i
always try to explain it to people but i
think you kind of had to be there
yeah yeah i mean you know what i'm
saying like my cousin had hadn't brought
like brought me to his attention like
he was like man from down south but i
was younger than cut out like a year or
two younger than him but it was like man
like around y'all aged me you know what
i'm saying so when they showed me him i
think the first song i heard about him
was um
i want to say not it wasn't no flocking
i think it was um
yeah hungry hungry like that was my
first son
i had a homeboy that's from down that
way you know i'm saying that i grew up
with like
he had to move from lauderdale he was he
had not taught like he was telling us
about i think it was like my ninth grade
yo
i wanna see y'all like my ninth grade
yeah i found out about him
and i was like yo that boy snapping you
know what i'm saying i actually ran into
him like a year or two later after that
on my birthday i seen him on my birthday
at the mall he was shopping and [ __ ] i
hadn't
you know chopped it up with him and [ __ ]
you know was it you know what i'm saying
like
me seeing him do that [ __ ] it was it was
amazing i'm like damn he
he opened the door for the young dudes
he really did man
i think i was like 15 at a time 16 at
the time when i seen dude during that
[ __ ] so yeah
i feel like a lot of the florida waves
that's happening now is like a direct
result as to what he kind of like the
foundation yeah
you know you got to give credit you know
what i'm saying yeah
kodak made away he did that 100 percent